ti senti Scusami caro e no no no
continua tranquillo non ti voglio dare
sempre vedi che mi sei girato ma ha
capito che non gli do fastidio quello Ma
cosa fa questo Cosa sta facendo
Non so quale dei due sia migliore a
ballare Posso provare a fare un canestro
prova eh eh
No no no cioè credimi che non volevi
quello è nudo
[Musica]
Non pensavo che il basket fosse così
violento vuoi vedere il CD di Gigi
D'Alessio come ti uccide fermo un attimo
allora questo è un mandarino Ok
mandarino è un mandarino come fai a
morire che guarda che strage
horror
questo è svenuto questi giocano a fare
ginnastica e Vite parallele
[Musica]